toute la communauté humaine des gens de
mer comme on les appelle est en deuil
vendredi trois sauveteurs des sables
d'olonne trois bénévoles de la snsm ont
trouvé la mort ils se sont noyés en
tentant de porter secours un marin
pêcheur en détresse les circonstances du
drame sont désormais connus la mère
était totalement démontée mais
lorsqu'ils ont reçu le signal de
détresse relayé par le cross etel
ils ne se sont pas posé de questions ce
sont les mots qu'avec françois de rugy
nous avons entendu des rescapés ils
n'ont pas hésité ils y sont allés parce
que c'est leur mission ils existent sont
allés parce que c'est leur raison d'être
et même de mourir malheureusement dans
cette circonstance
depuis que cette terre et battue par la
marée sans fin de la vie et de la mort
tous ceux qui portent secours pour
sauver des vies savent qu'un jour ils
peuvent mourir pour eux rien n'a plus
d'importance que leur devoir et parfois
même le devoir
jusqu'à l'ultime sacrifice le président
de la république a décidé d'honorer ceux
qui sont morts je pense que nous
pourrions aussi honorer ceux qui restent
vivants parce que c'est le même courage
parce que c'est le même équipage
monsieur le premier ministre je
m'adresse à vous non pas en tant que
chef du gouvernement
je m'adresse à l'homme à celui qui
appartient aussi à ce peuple de la mer
que je connais bien qui a été
merveilleusement décrit dans un ouvrage
qui a fait date à mme marc elder je
voudrais que vous preniez ici un
engagement un seul devant bien sûr le
sénat de la république mais aussi devant
ceux qui ne sont plus devant ceux qui
sont encore vivants je voudrais que vous
puissiez vous engager à tirer
toutes les leçons dès lors que le moment
de la décision sera venu toutes les
leçons de son drame merci monsieur le
premier ministre pour vous répondre
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre edouard philippe monsieur le
premier ministre monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le président retailleau avant
de vous répondre je voudrais m'associer
évidemment aux propos que vous avez
tenus et que le président du sénat
gérard larcher vient de tenir pour dire
mon émotion ma reconnaissance
mon admiration aussi et la force des
pensées que j'adresse à la famille aux
familles des victimes
à tous ceux qui se sont engagés avec eux
dans cette formidable aventure que le
sauvetage en mer et à tous ceux qui ont
été incroyablement frappé ému par ce
drame on vendredi dernier vous avez posé
monsieur le président retailleau avec
une émotion bien légitime deux questions
cette émotion c'est celle d'un
responsable politique d'un français d'un
citoyen français qui sait reconnaître
des héros quand il les voit et qui était
mue par le sens du devoir
le courage dont font preuve des
concitoyens qui n'en attendent rien si
ce n'est le sentiment d'accomplir une
mission pour laquelle ils s'engagent et
votre émotion elle était je le crois je
le sais encore accrue par le fait que
vous connaissez la mer que vous êtes élu
d'un département où on sait ce que c'est
que la course au large
que l'on sait ce que c'est que la
difficulté de l'activité de marins
pêcheurs que l'on sait un département où
l'on sait que la mère donne beaucoup
parfois elle reprend et tous les gens de
mer tous ceux qui ont grandi près de la
mer tous ceux qui l'aiment savent que
rien n'est plus fort que les éléments
que lorsque lorsque la menace arrive
lorsque le gros temps est prévu il est
raisonnable de ne pas imaginer qu'on
pourrait être plus fort que les éléments
et pourtant alors même qu'on sait que
les hommes ne sont jamais plus fort que
les éléments les sauveteurs en mer
sortent sans se poser de questions
alors même qu'ils savent que c'est
dangereux alors même qu'ils savent que
c'est trop dangereux
ils le font sans s'interroger nous
l'avons tous vu dans des circonstances
variées et nous savons tous l'incroyable
admiration dont dans sont l'objet c'est
mais ces femmes en orange comme on les
appelle parfois une admiration qui
souvent passent par des gestes ou des
mots sympathiques qui leur sont
adressées par des dons par une fidélité
aussi à ce qu'il représente
je vais vous dire monsieur le président
retailleau que la république c'est
reconnaître des héros comme vous comme
nous tous lorsqu'elle en voit et je n'ai
aucun doute sur le fait qu'elle sera
distingué à l'attention de l'ensemble de
nos concitoyens ceux qui ce jour ont
pris un risque en connaissance de cause
pour servir et pour sauver un marin je
vais vous dire également monsieur le
président retailleau que nous avons dans
le passé déjà accru l'effort et c'était
légitime mais c'était juste l'effort
budgétaire notamment que nous faisons à
destination de la snsm
je voudrais d'ailleurs attiré
l'attention de l'ensemble du sénat comme
de l'ensemble de la représentation
parlementaire sur le fait que nous avons
considérablement accru les sommes qui
sont donnés à la snsm met en valeur
absolue elles ne sont pas très
importantes
le modèle de sauvetage en mer tel qu'il
existe aujourd'hui n'est pas un modèle
qui repose sur des très fortes dotations
budgétaires loin s'en faut il repose sur
le bénévolat y reposent sur les dons sur
le bénévolat complet et nous devons donc
à la lumière de ce drame nous interroger
sur la permanence de ce modèle vous
savez monsieur le président ohio qu'en
2017 puis en 2018 j'ai personnellement
présidé le comité interministériel de la
mer d'abord à brest en 2017 puis à
dunkerque en 2018
j'ai l'intention de présider celui qui
se tiendra en 2019
je propose qu'à l'ordre du jour du
comité interministériel de la mer en
nous nous interrogions sur
le modèle du sauvetage en mer ce qu'il
faut préserver absolument dans ses
valeurs dans ses compétences
est ce qu'il faut réparer ou peut être
développée c'est une question qui
intéresse tous les gens de mer mais au
fond c'est une question qui intéresse
tous ceux dans notre pays qu'ils savent
qu'il n'ya rien de plus beau que de
servir ses concitoyens et que
l'engagement de ces sauveteurs en mer
c'est exactement cela servir ses
concitoyens
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]